[Music]
that's max Dubrow Heather and Terry
Dubrow is 13 year old daughter taking
the stage with Quiet Riot at the world
famous whiskey a go go in Hollywood as
we're driving up she was like oh wait
it's at the whiskey is it yes but I
don't think she realized the gravitas of
the whole thing
[Music]
only et was invited inside Max's
soundcheck alongside for Mom I know the
backstory but I don't know that
everybody knows the backstory of why
you're getting to perform with Quiet
Riot
so my uncle on my dad's side was the
lead singer quiet right and then he
passed away and so I'm gonna be singing
kind of it like what we use doing
[Music]
Terri's brother kevin was quiet riots
frontman until 2007 when he tragically
passed away you got the job you're in
the band
it was exactly 10 years to the day of
his death that max got to perform with
the band it's a little bittersweet but I
know Kevin would be super proud how did
it come together
so Frankie Banali who was Kevin's best
friend Kevin Dubrow Terry's brother
Frankie Banali and James Durbin who's
the new lead singer of Quiet Riot who
you remember from American Idol Frankie
and James came on my podcast Heather
Dubrow his world and we were talking and
hanging out and Frankie said is Mac
still singing and I said yes and he said
would she ever want to perform with us
and I went yeah that sounds pretty
awesome did she give you any advice
about hitting the stage as controlling
as I am and you know I'm you know I'm a
little controlling that's the total
energy I know but when it comes to stuff
like this you know I believe in her
she's fun and talented and amazing and I
said to her let's have fun cuz that's
all it's about it's it's a cool life
experience and just have fun and kill it
it was music something you are thinking
seriously about pursuing um kind of I
also want to get into the medical field
so those are very different but that's
so funny because I have the musical
background and Terry's a doctor and so
she likes both so she really is an
amalgam of the two of us and I said
alright so she'll be a singing doctor
yeah there you go that's uh that seems
like another reality show for the family
[Laughter]
[Music]